GONNA GO AHEAD AND START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND HOPEFULLY
PEOPLE WILL GET HERE GOOD
MORNING WELCOME TO THE APRIL
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING- WE ONLY HAVE
ONE BILL TODAY AB ONE OH FOR-
BY MYSELF BEFORE WE BEGIN WE
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES
TO COVER FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THINK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
WHO IS HERE SEVEN TODAY FOR MR
LEVINE. AND THEN- MISS FRIEDMAN
AND MISS REAVIS- SUPPOSEDLY
COMING TO SUB FOR OTHER PEOPLE
SO. WE ARE KEEPING A PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BETWEEN ONE ANOTHER IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND I'M ONLY
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER SPACES
FOR PEOPLE TO COME IN A WATCH I
DON'T SEE THAT ANYBODY IS HERE
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE. THAT
PEOPLE ARE EXPECTED TO- IT HERE
TO PUBLIC TO QUORUM IF YOU-
SCREAM YELL TALK ABOUT THINGS
THAT ARE IRRELEVANT TO THE
ISSUE AT HAND OR- DISRUPT THE
MEETING WE WILL. ASK YOU TO
STOP AND IT SO. I THE CALL LINE
FOR TESTIMONY TODAY IS.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH MODERATED PHONE SERVICE
YOU MAY CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2081 AND MY STAFF WILL
TRY TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW THAT WE ALWAYS ACCEPT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEES EMAIL SYSTEM AND
THROUGH THE POSTAL SERVICE AS
DESCRIBED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AND- I
DON'T QUITE SEE QUORUM YET.
SINCE I AM. I NEED TO- RIGHT OR
NOT I THINK THERE'S. NINE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN.
EIGHT NINE TEN YEAH WE'RE GOOD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ESTABLISH FOR. GONZALEZ PRESENT
BIGELOW PRESENT BONTA. CALDERON
THE VIDEO. TELL DALAI AB. FONG
GABRIEL. EDUARDO GARCIA KALRA.
BURKE ROBERT RIVAS SURE
FRIEDMAN. THREE OF US OKAY.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
AB IF NOBODY'S OFFENDED VITAMIN
A PRESENT FROM RIGHT HERE SINCE
I AM THE ONLY BILL AND NOT SO
I'LL HAND THIS OVER TO MR
BIGELOW TO CHAIR THE MEETING.
WELL WELCOME TO EVERYONE ON
THIS FINE DAY WE HAVE ONE BILL
BEFORE US TODAY IS AB ONE OH
FOUR BY MISS GONZALEZ. WOULD
YOU LIKE 2% SURE THANK YOU-
MISTRY'S TEN MEMBERS AB ONE OF
FOUR AIMS TO EMPOWER STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH A
VARIETY OF LEARNING RECOVERY
OPPORTUNITIES. AND HOLD
STUDENTS HARMLESS FROM THE
CHALLENGES CREATED BY COVERT
NINETEEN IT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
ABOUT. WELL WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND A MOTION WAS BY MR
DALLI- I THOUGHT I FOR. FROM
THIS RIVAS WE HAD A SECOND- CAN
WE GO TO THE PHONES. OPERATOR
YES THE CHAIR. DO WE HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS OR PRESENTERS ON THE
PHONE. DO YOU HAVE MILLION JAN
BUT I BELIEVE HE'S ONLY FOR
QUESTIONS. OKAY ARE THE MILLION
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OKAY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DO
YOU HAVE A GOOD MORNING-
COCHAIR BIGELOW AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND CHECK AND BALANCE-
THIS IS MILLION WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THE FIELD- WE DO NOT THIS
BILL CREATES SIGNIFICANT LOCAL
COSTS AND A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND BY
REQUIRING ALL ONE THOUSAND
THIRTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO ADOPT A NEW
RETENTION POLICY AND PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE NOTICE HE STUDENTS
AND FAMILY. DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF THE DISTRICT COSTS
COULD RANGE FROM ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SERVING
STUDENTS IN GRADES NINE TO
TWELVE MY THOUGHTS WITHOUT NEW
POLICIES AROUND GREAT CHANGES
AND PROVIDE EXPANDED
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS NOT
ON TRACK TO GRADUATE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEARS THESE COSTS COULD RANGE
FROM FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER SCHOOL DISTRICT OR MORE
DEPENDING ON THE OPPORTUNITIES
PROVIDED. AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS UTILIZING THEM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT STILL INCREASES THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN THE FIFTH YEAR
OF INSTRUCTION THIS BILL COULD
INCREASE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA COSTS. ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL HAVE AN
ESTIMATED ONE TIME COST OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO DEVELOP AN
APPLICATION FOR GREAT CHANGES
FOR USE BY LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES. BY MAY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TO DEVELOP AND
COSTA LIST OF POSTSECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY WILL ACCEPT
PASSED FOR CREDIT FOR ADMISSION
PURPOSES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND FOR THE RECORD YOU HAD NO
POSITION ON THIS BILL. THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION. CAN WE GO BACK
TO THE PHONES ARE THERE S
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. ON THE PHONE OPERATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO NOW. AT THIS TIME
IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q.
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE'LL BRING IT BACK
FOR QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
FROM MEMBERS DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS AND NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION- WE HAD A MOTIONS-
BY MISS ALLEN A SECOND I
MISREAD THIS WOULD YOU. LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECT LAST NIGHT OF.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL OF
COLORADO. GONZALEZ HI BIGELOW
HI BONTA RIGHT CALDERON. MMHM
CHAU DALY. DAVIES FONG. GABRIEL
IN ORDER GARCIA. CHOLERA FIRST.
ROBERT RIVAS THREE OF US.
FRIEDMAN HE- SEVERAL DIFFERENT
I BELIEVE THAT GETS OUT ANA A
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR NOW WE ALL KNOW HOW TO
CALL THE ROLL OF ROPES I JUST
WANNA HAVE FUN HERE TODAY IS
FOR THE REMEDY WAS ADJOURNED.